this altitude this episode is brought to
you by convertkit my go-to email service
provider a lot of you have asked me what
I use for email and I've been hesitant
to tell you because I don't want to give
them the hug of death and have my own
service drop so after much consideration
I finally said yes to convertkit being a
sponsor email is a huge priority for me
and I trust convertkit as my ESP my
email service provider it's the only
platform that I can completely control
and customize and I need a service that
ensures the right information is sent to
my followers and listeners and I cannot
afford downtime I've very little
patience for it so I tried all sorts of
different platforms and ultimately
selected convertkit because they deliver
on what matters most to me and my team
easy to use systems split testing super
important and resending technology say
to unopened high rates of deliverability
and excellent customer service when I've
needed something from them when my team
has needed something from them they've
always been there so whether you run a
business or just have a professional
blog let's say convertkit offers
email automation which allows you to
send well-timed targeted content to your
audience or your customers the platform
has all sorts of integrations with more
than 35 services including say hosting
sites such as WordPress e-commerce
platforms like Shopify lead capture
technology like bounce exchange or sumo
and many many more they offer plans that
can adjust to meet the size of your
business and they can scale with you so
convertkit can handle you whether you
have a thousand people or 1 million
people on your email list let's take a
look convert kit.com forward slash Tim
let's see-oh nver t ki t com forward
slash Tim and you can get your first
month for free that way you can test the
platform kick the tires make sure that
it works for you and your business and
if you're like me hopefully fingers
crossed
because I only like to recommend things
that scale and do really well for
everybody I hope that you find they get
the job done that's certainly been the
case for me again that is convertkit
comm forward slash Tim for a free month
of email services check it out this
episode is brought to you by 4 Sigma
tech founded by the genius Finn's who
lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty much every day either
that or the chaga which is decaf as a
separate version and I use both of these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you going let you up like
a Christmas tree so definitely check it
out people are always asking me what I
use for cognitive enhancement and for
right now this is the answer I try to
force this on all of my houseguests it
is a hell of a thing if I have employees
or people come over who aren't working
on projects with me I always try to feed
it to them because I'm going to get the
limitless effect gets a lot more out of
them the first time I mentioned this
product and for sig Matic on the podcast
their products sold out in less than a
week so you may want to check them out
soon if you're listening to this and the
coffee tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you would get in a
regular cup of coffee I don't get any
jitters acid reflux or any stomach burn
any of that it's very unusual and very
very cool so if you don't like caffeine
they also offer very strong but caffeine
free mushroom elixirs which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the moment which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm
forward slash Tim that's for sig Matic
fo you are SI g ma TI c calm forward
slash Tim and use the code tim TI m to
get 20
percent off of your first order and
they're not that expensive anyway if you
are in the experimental mindset I do not
think you'll be disappointed it's a
trauma no ladies and germs this is Tim
Ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the Tim Ferriss show where it is my
job to interview people from many
diverse fields different arenas of
competition or lack thereof to dissect
what makes them the best at what they do
the habits routines philosophies beliefs
etc that you can apply in your own life
this episode we have Sharon Salzberg si
L Z BER G you can find her on Twitter I
believe it's just at Sharon Salzberg and
Sharon is a central figure in the field
of meditation a world-renowned teacher
and New York Times bestselling author
she has played a crucial role from the
very beginning in some respects in
bringing meditation and mindfulness
practices to the West and very much into
mainstream culture since 1974 when she
first began teaching she is the
co-founder of the Insight Meditation
Society in Barre Massachusetts and the
author of several books including the
neuro Times bestseller real happiness
her seminal work loving-kindness which
we'll get into in real happiness at work
very well known for her down-to-earth
style and you'll get a first-hand view
of that when you listen to this she
offers a secular and modern approach to
Buddhist teachings making them more
accessible than I think some of the
esoteric varieties would be two type-a
personalities like you friend listening
to this podcast probably she's a
columnist for on being contributor to
Huffington Post and the host of her own
podcast the Metta our M e TT a and we
will get into what that means her newest
book is real love the art of mindful
connection and I wanted to speak with
Sharon for a long time I've read her
work I've heard her audio and it's very
meaningfully impacted how I operate in
the world how I perceived myself and
others and ultimately that has made me
both more effective and given me a
greater sense of well-being so I hope
that you
whole some of that from this
conversation we bounced all over the
place I asked some very personal
self-interested questions which I think
make the answers practical also and
there you have it
so I hope you enjoy as much as I did
this wide-ranging conversation with
Sharon Salzberg Sharon welcome to the
show thank you I have been looking
forward to this conversation for some
time and I'm glad we could finally make
it happen the construction around your
apartment in New York notwithstanding
and I know that you have to be out at a
set time so I'd like to just jump right
into it and begin at the beginning in a
sense with a question related to your
youth and if you're comfortable sharing
the story could you tell us about your
experience that you had I think it was
at nine years old when you were dressed
in your Halloween costume and watching
Nat King Cole yes I my mother died when
I was 9 and it was that night when I was
9 that my mother started hemorrhaging I
was alone in the house with her and she
I got ended up getting an ambulance and
she went to the hospital and she died
about two weeks later and it was much
later when I was writing a book called
faith which was kind of like my faith
journey that I looked back over my life
from the time I was born till the time I
went to college at 16 and I realized
that I had lived in five different
family configurations alone at a time
and each one of them had been altered by
trauma or death or some kind of really
no terrible circumstance and what was
your relationship like with your father
when you were younger well my parents
had had divorced when I was 4 and my
father as far as I can recall was really
like my hero you know he was he was the
love in my life and and then he was just
gone he completely disappeared and there
was no contact whatsoever from the time
I lived with my mother after
was after they split up and her siblings
from the time I was fortunate um I was
nine and at that point after she died I
ended up living with my father's parents
whom I hardly knew and that was the
first time that contact was
reestablished between us and he didn't
reappear in my life my actual you know
physical presence until I was 11 and by
that time it was clear he'd suffered you
know really severe mental illness he was
drinking he was gambling and he was
really lost and he came back when my
grandfather died when I was 11 and was
in the house for just about six weeks
when he took an overdose of sleeping
pills and then entered the mental health
system where he stayed for the next you
know significant number of years before
he died so and it was part of that that
was kind of my recollection because I
was I was sort of part of a family
system where this was never ever really
talked about and so I had as one can
imagine what these feelings inside and I
didn't know what to do with them and
people that always tell me oh your
father accidentally took an extra pill
you know he just didn't remember that
he'd taken sleeping pills already and
and it was only when I was in college
that years later they thought wait a
minute that's a lot to have happen so
that you then end up in a mental health
facility for the rest of your life and I
it took a lot to figure out oh you know
people of course we're trying to protect
me they're trying to keep me happy keep
me going but it was on the basis of
denying what I actually was feeling and
so it was very destructive when did you
have your first encounter with Buddhism
or mindfulness how did that into your
life I was I went to college I was 16
when I was a sophomore I took an Asian
philosophy course and honestly looking
back as far as I can tell it was kind of
like happenstance you know like it was
on Tuesday it fit in with my schedule
right right here I didn't start too
early exactly nothing couldn't do that
and so I took this class and it was
really in that class that I encountered
Buddhism for the first time really I
mean I knew you know I was the 60s so
there's all kind of around in a way but
it was the first time I really heard
what the Buddha taught in the first part
that was incredibly important given
everything I've been through was just
the teaching about suffering that
suffering is a part of life and it's not
just me it's not something not something
to be ashamed of and feel I'm aberrant
and different you know which of course
is what I primarily felt my entire life
is like I'm different you know people
have two parents people have you know
same parents so other things are going
on for other people and but not me but
all of a sudden it was like I was part
of the human family that not life is not
always pleasant it doesn't always go our
way it's not that it's Graham or
horrible but you know it's
it contains suffering for everybody and
that was like a huge liberation and then
I heard in that class that there was
actually something you could do about
the suffering in your life not the
suffering of circumstance but all the
ways we hold it the ways we you know we
can have pain and we can hold it in
isolation or we can hold it as feeling
part of the human family or we can have
rage or we can have compassion and
there's so many options and I heard
there was this stuff you could do they
were actual methods or techniques called
meditation and if you did them you could
be happier so I was gonna school in
Buffalo New York I looked around Buffalo
didn't see it anywhere everywhere now
but doesn't see it you know so there was
an independent study program at the
school and I created a project I said I
want to go to India and study meditation
and they said okay so off I went ha have
you had you traveled outside of the
country prior to going to India no I had
not I was just teaching a class earlier
today I said you know I'd never even
been to California I went to India I
grew up in New York City I went to
school in Buffalo they've been one
family trip to Florida in my youth I was
it and then I was on a plane so I had
read that a few days before leaving to
India I
went to talk by a famed Tibetan master
and I'd love for you to tell us a bit
about that a because I have no idea how
to pronounce this name properly and and
be what you took away from it his name
is Chuck your Trump remember che is his
first trip to the United States and I
don't know who did his tour he ended up
in Buffalo New York he later became the
founder of Naropa Institute and
Shambhala publications all kinds of
things and but this was his first trip
and he was giving a lecture not at my
university but at a nearby college this
was maybe three or four days before my
friends and I were gonna leave for India
and we didn't know where we're gonna go
I just know I wanted a steady meditation
so we went to his talk and they asked
for written questions and I wrote out
the question like where should I go I'm
leaving in a few days for India I want
to study Buddhist meditation where
should I go and and he had this big pile
of questions in front of him and he
pulled it out and he read it out loud
and then he was silent for a moment and
then he said I think you had perhaps
best follow the pretense of accident I
think you had perhaps best follow the
pretense of accident and that was it it
was like no addresses no handy monastery
guidebook you know nothing just follow
the pretense of accident it's exactly
how it happened it's a pretense of
accident meaning no set plan allow
things to unfold as they unfold is that
what that means it means that and I
think it also it would have meant for me
was stay close to your intention hmm you
know like my intention was so strong and
my yearning was so strong that it it
really saved me in a way staying close
to that because they were naturally some
disappointments along the way and you
know ways I couldn't I couldn't imagine
how things were gonna turn out like I
started out in Dharamsala in India
because I knew the Dali Lama lived there
I'd heard he was a Buddhist and
there were you know amazing teachers and
opportunities there but it was one of
those situations where it didn't quite
work like I'd go to a meditation class
and because remember I was really into
the practical how-to what's the stuff
you know that's gonna help make me happy
and I go to this meditation class and
they say well the teacher had to go to
the dentist at the other end of India
come back in two weeks you know the
translators out of town try again later
you know and it just wasn't happening
and I went to a Tibetan restaurant one
day and I overheard a conversation where
these two women were saying that there
was gonna be an international yoga
conference in New Delhi and I thought
nope great I'll go there that's where
I'll find my teacher and I went there
and it was a really dispirited time
where the low point was probably when
these Yogi's and Swami's were up on a
stage pushing and shoving against each
other to be the first to grab the mic
and speak yeah sitting buffalo this is
terrible and actually Dan Goleman who
you know is now very well known for his
book emotional intelligence and and his
work but in those days he was a graduate
student in psychology at Harvard and he
was studying meditation for some reason
he was delivering a paper at this
conference so I went to his lecture and
he said at the end of the lecture that
he was on his way to this town called
bodhgaya
in northern India he was gonna do an
intensive ten day meditation retreat
which was like an immersion course free
of cultural baggage and really the
direct stuff and I thought that's it and
it was it so I was huge about dying and
the pretense of accident what happened
in in both gaya if I'm saying that
correctly I probably am NOT yes all
right great I'll take it now you were
what happened there um well there was a
teacher and SN Goenka who had just left
Burma he was teaching intensive 10-day
meditation retreats where you were
basically
meditating under his guidance all day
he'd give one lecture at night we were
we had certain silent days in silent
times and he would just keep modulating
the instruction until we'd come to the
end so we did meditation first on
feeling the breath and just basic
concentration and then kind of scanning
your attention and through your body
feeling these different sensations and
then the very last thing that he taught
was a loving-kindness meditation which
many years later became sort of my main
meditation my personal meditation and
also in terms of my teaching and writing
so that was like the ten days it was
really like an immersion and it was a
tremendous time of discovery not only
did we forge lifelong friendships
because here does all these years later
that was January of 1971 that age of my
first retreat and I just saw Dan Goleman
last night for example and you know we
are tremendous friends this whole group
of people and it really was about
learning was about discovering and the
lab the vehicle was ourselves so the
timing of the our conversation is very
opportune because I'm actually in about
six days time doing my very first 10-day
silent retreat that's at spirit rock and
I've never had never had this experience
I am apprehensive excited but
apprehensive about it jack Kornfield
will be there so I'm very interested to
engage with him before I have to stop
talking
what what what advice would you give to
someone going into that type of
experience for the first time I think
that's great and congratulations thank
you um I would love to hear from you
when you come out I mean there are a few
things one is the thing most people feel
trepidation about seems to be as the
silence and the
you know people show up in and say I
don't think that I can be silent or my
partner doesn't think I can be silent or
one woman came and said they're doing a
betting pool in my office they don't
think a silent but of all the elements
of the retreat it's almost always one of
the things people point to is the most
beautiful because it's like from once in
our lives we can really fully be
ourselves and we don't have to present
ourselves to others and think about
their experience versus our experience
and you know am i witty enough am I am i
strong enough for anything we can just
be and it's a beautiful beautiful gift
to give to oneself I'd also say the
first few days of a retreat like the
first day and a half let's say are
usually pretty rough even if you have
tremendous experience in meditation and
in retreats it's just an adjustment
period it's like I you know forty some
years later forty five years later if I
go into an intensive retreat the
beginning is is usually you know I say
there are two voices that arise inside
my head one voice says there's nothing
happening here must be time to go to
sleep so even if I slept for ten hours
it's just like I conk out and the other
voice says there's nothing happening
here let's make something happen you
know the next book the next Center
whatever you know all these fantasies
start pouring in and so it's like a
careening almost from sleepiness to
restlessness and sleepiness to
restlessness and that will definitely
change and it will even out and you'll
have an experience of both energy and
calm at the same time but the most
tricky thing is believing the thought
that tends to arise that says oh no nine
more days exactly like this you know
which we tend to believe and if you can
remember don't believe that thought it's
gonna keep changing you know just just
keep going it will really it will change
and you'll feel really much more
completely there thank you I'm really
excited about it and I'm excited yeah
I'm really excited about it and I'd love
to hear how you let's just say you had a
room of open-minded intelligent people
who are all typing
that's basically most of the people
listening to this so imagine you have
these people and they are in the boat
that I was in for a very long time and
I'm not gonna lie occasionally I end up
back on that boat which is meditating
this doesn't seem to work for me I've
tried a B and C and it's just not the
tool to fix my particular set of
problems I can't sit still I can't do
fill-in-the-blank but I would like to
make an attempt because I recognize at
least the benefits I've seen in other
people and read about and so on how do
you get those people started what do you
say to them well my first question is
about what is that Blanc that we're
trying to fill in because a lot of
people have really intense expectations
of what meditation is supposed to do and
they're often wrong you know so a lot of
people have said to me for example I
tried that once I felt that it and I
said well I couldn't stop thinking I
couldn't make my mind blank I couldn't
have only beautiful thoughts I couldn't
keep the anxiety from coming up I
couldn't keep sleepiness at bay and we
say of course you cannot fail at it it's
impossible to fail at it because you
cannot be having the wrong experience
the question is not what is happening
but how are you relating to what's
happening that's the whole terrain of
the transformation is how much presence
how much balance how much kindness how
much compassion are you bringing forth
in relationship to what's coming up and
of course there's a kind of social
pressure these days like if you ran into
a friend you know what you'd like to be
able to say as well you know I had a
little bit of restlessness in the
beginning but then there's peace like
it's unfathomable peace just descended
upon me and then it started like
shimmering at the edges and turned into
bliss and there was bliss and peace and
you know that's what we want to say we
don't want to say well my knee hurt my
back hurt and I got restless and I got
angry and they judge myself then I fell
asleep you know but in truth really in
truth it's not just consolation you know
but in truth from the point of view of
mindfulness it doesn't matter where is
the question is okay how were you with
the sleepiness how kind were you when
you got angry you know I enjoyed
yourself
you know how much could you include in
that field of awareness and those things
are much more subtle and they're not as
satisfying you know and they're
certainly not as satisfying to talk
about but that's the whole point
so I would really want to know what
someone's expectations are and then I
mean you can be reassured like you're
gonna sit with Jack because I've been
teaching for a very long time and you
know there's not like a cookie cutter
description of what it's supposed to
look like maybe for you he'll suggest
more walking meditation than sitting
meditation maybe he'll you know suggest
a more structured approach because that
is is proving useful for you or maybe a
less structured approach or you know
there's so many possibilities no when
you are say advising someone who is
really making an effort to create
meditation as a practice much like they
would brush their teeth or do something
else
what are and I think what you already
said is very helpful in the sense that
it's not the content of the experience
it's how you relate to the various
things that come up during your
experience and I I remember one thing
that helped me as a typically very well
suppose I had self described as sort of
driven type-a personality was the idea
that it's this is something that someone
said to me I don't recall who it was but
it's not it's it's not important or you
shouldn't judge the the session based on
how many times you lose focus of X
whether that's a mantra or a breath or
whatever but because the practice itself
is coming back to the focus and thinking
of it in terms of repetitions in that
context really helped me to relate
better to what I viewed as these
horrible distractions but not realize
and like no that's the lowering of the
weight and then your job is to lift it
back up and that's right that's exactly
right
are there other mental frameworks or
analogies that you've
very helpful much like that for for
people to keep in mind when they're
sitting down and their knee hurts and
they're having these various of thinking
of the last episode look at Rick and
Morty that they watched or whatever
are there other great show but other are
there any other analogies or
recommendations that allow people to be
easier on themselves and make progress
through relating to themselves in an
easier way as opposed to straining yeah
I mean that you know that's also a great
question and there's several levels to
that in the kind of immediate level what
you said is the most important thing
sometimes we say the healing is in the
return not in never having wandered to
begin with the most important thing is
that coming back and in some ways it's
the opportunity to come back to the
distraction gives us you know and so you
can come back you could need to let go
and come back a billion times and it
would be fine because that's the actual
training one of my teachers mr. Benton
teachers son remember Chaney called it
exercising the letting go muscle so the
secret ingredients in that is actually
self-compassion which means that you
realize you blew it you your mind
wandered or in life maybe realize you're
made a mistake or you know things didn't
really go the way that you wanted them
to and rather than spending next year
and a half castigating yourself about
that you know it's realizing okay
lessons learned or or maybe I need to
make amends or maybe there's something I
need to do to come back into bounds but
I need to do that with kindness toward
myself and and you know that makes the
process go a whole lot quicker and and
its restorative rather than you know if
you just blame yourself and you call
yourself a failure and you get down on
yourself and you judge yourself it lasts
forever and you're exhausted and it's
not really resilience it's not really
the space with which we can start again
so if you start finding yourself doing
that in the process of meditating that's
the signal you know to remember like
this happens you know this is the
process this is actually the path it's
not that I need remedial work you know
I'm the worst meditator that ever lived
this is what it looks like for everybody
let me just start over and start over
it's really very important when when
you're thinking back on the many people
you've taught and interacted with
readers who've given you feedback and so
on have you identified any type of what
I might call minimum effective dose and
what I mean by that is if if you if you
look at say certain types of resistance
training or physical training you you
that you can research and experiment
with the frequency the duration the
intensity and figure out which
parameters you respond best to and same
is true for four different aspects of
diet or drugs certainly right you do too
much there are unintended side effects
you do too little you don't get the
effect you're looking for I've noticed
for myself at least that this is just
for me but that may be 20 minutes a day
first thing in the morning for five to
ten days straight is about the minimum
dose that I need to click into feeling
generally much more relaxed with
meditation but have you and then after
that point I can actually dial back the
frequency if need be but I need that
first loading period have you observed
any sort of generalizable minimum
effective dose for from people or it's
like well like X Y & Z is too little too
and frequently this is it too much
you're more likely to quit but like this
kind of this is the Goldilocks
in-between that I've seen to really
deliver the most benefits for the least
inconvenience for lack of a better term
but how would you think about that well
it just so happens that last night I was
with some friends they were giving a
lecture
Dan Goleman Richie Davidson who's a
neuroscientist at university of
wisconsin-madison studying meditation on
Jon kabat-zinn who founded mindfulness
based stress reduction and Richie from
the point of view of neuroscience said
that nine minutes a day will actually
change your brain hmm but you have to do
it every day
and I often think of retreats like the
intensive retreat as a period of really
deepening confidence and clarity about
the practice so that you have better
tools to actually practice every day
somebody also made a comment about how
you know it may not be the healthiest
thing in the world to think about the
least possible amount I need to put into
this thing some result you know so so I
would Pat it some I wouldn't just try to
do nine minutes day usually I'd say 20
minutes a day more if you can just
because the first five minutes or so in
a daily sitting tend to be the most
distracted like what's it sound and I
think it's my refrigerator do they still
have refrigerator repair people I don't
know I've been needing a refrigerator to
this left Sears anymore I don't know you
know and it's almost like it's discharge
of tension for a little bit and then if
you can hang in there you'd get a chance
to go deeper
having discharged all of that and so
it's just it's just more fruitful in a
way if you can do 20 minutes but if you
only have three I'd say do three
everybody says it's the everydayness of
it which seems to be the most potent
thing and for a beginner what would you
recommend this 20 minutes look like what
would the protocol or the format of this
20 minutes look like well there there
are kind of three main thrusts of the
tradition and which were reflected in my
first retrieve the first is
concentration where we try to settle our
attention and have it be more stable and
get more centered so that usually means
choosing an object whether it's the
breath or a mantra or whatever it is
Marcus is usually the breath and
settling your attention on that object
and then simply returning every time you
realize you've wandered over time you
get a sense of first of all a tremendous
amount of energy returning to you
because there's an awful lot of energy
that
could be available to us but isn't
because it's scattered all over the
place and we keep gathering it and
returning it and and you feel the kind
of empowerment of that and also a kind
of integration of our being it's like
all that scattered miss is also a kind
of fragmentation and we kind of bring it
all together and then there's
mindfulness which actually is is an
extension of that where we not only pay
attention to the single object like the
breath but we take we pay attention to
our emotional worlds and what's coming
up predominantly in and our bodies and
what we're feeling and all kinds of
things with that same kind of balanced
awareness which is why we say
mindfulness is the is the basis for
insight you know we understand so much
more about everything so and one example
is I often talk about sitting and
looking at my own fear trying to be as
mindful as I can which means not
condemning it and also not diving into
it and having it take over and I feel
I've seen a lot so as one example I felt
that you know unlike the kind of world's
Maxim that were afraid of the unknown I
find that I'm really afraid when I think
I do know and it's gonna be really bad
and it's all the stories I tell myself
that really get me going and even in the
midst of that if I remind myself you
know what you don't know and I feel
relief I feel a sense of space and you
know we look at our desire and we see
look how much loneliness there is in
there we look at our anger we say look
how much sadness there is in there and
wherever we look we see into change that
look at that I thought it was so forever
I thought that was all that I ever felt
but look at that it's always changing
and so all of that just kind of
naturally arises from paying attention
and then the third kind of thrust of the
skills training in meditation is
loving-kindness or compassion and that
was the last meditation that going to
introduced it my 10-day course it was
just an hour so but it so ignited me
that it became you know something I got
very devoted to and that's threaded
throughout both the self compassion we
have to feel for ourselves to be able to
do the first to concentration in my
phone as well and then there are
distinct
which are just devoted to the deepening
of loving-kindness and compassion now is
loving-kindness
I'm not terribly familiar with
loving-kindness but I call and please
correct me if I'm miss applying the the
label but I read some writing by a
gentleman named chade-meng tan who out
of google you may know and a friend of
mine so Meng introduced me to a very
simple practice thinking of two people
you initially people you know well and
care for and just wishing them to be
happy in the most in in the sense in the
most abstract of ways but it didn't seem
to matter that it was abstract even
though I love the concrete and I did
this for a period of time about a year
ago at night just before winding down
and going to bed and it it had a
tremendous impact on my happiness if we
want to call it that or self-reported
well-being over the subsequent ten days
I mean I was in such a good mood and the
only variable that I could identify that
I changed was wishing to people
happiness for say two or three minutes a
piece every night is that does that fall
in the category of loving kindness
practice it does alright I was really
really just impressed by how profound
the impact was because I'm not gonna lie
I expected it to do very very little and
I why does it appear to have such an
impact I mean I don't feel like I'm a
jerk I mean I do like to wish other
people to be happy and I try very hard
in my books and so on to facilitate that
but what why does it seem to have such
an impact well I think it's because it
trains our attention to be different
it's like we're paying attention
differently you know so for example in
if you were doing it in a formal
sequence and you may in the retreat I'm
not really sure you start with offering
loving kindness to yourself and then you
move on to those people that you like
you know
and moving through those you feel
neutral toward maybe somebody who plays
a role in your life that you see now and
then you move on to offering loving
kindness to more difficult people for
you and then finally all beings
everywhere all of life and I think the
reason it works and it does work and I
also know you know it's easy to be
cynical about it it sounds so small see
and but it's actually very powerful so
the question is do you want to make the
experiment or not or is it just so
off-putting that you'd rather some
people fear but it is I think all about
paying attention differently so for
example in looking yourself if you're
the kind of person who at the end of the
day you sort of evaluate yourself like
how did I do today and if you're the
kind of person who pretty well only
remembers the things you did wrong and
the mistakes you made this check that's
right you know almost like asking
yourself anything else happened today
like any good within me and it's not to
be conflict avoidant and pretend we're
perfect or anything but it's that kind
of singular obsessive look at what's
wrong that we want to broaden and so we
want a little airtime for the rest you
know so what do we pay attention to and
who do we pay attention to as a
fascinating question who do we look
right through who doesn't count there
doesn't matter you know who's like an
object for us and this is one of the
places where that neutral person is
really interesting because they're just
the shopkeeper just the drycleaner or
whatever they are very easy to objectify
very easy to look through so what
happens when we look at them instead of
through them which is in effect what
we're doing in the practice and how do
we pay attention are we really there
ever are we you know talking to a
stranger and thinking about our email
and whatever else we need to do and we
actually arrive and that is exactly the
same movement we do in the concentration
meditation it's like we realize we're a
million miles away we come back you know
so what's what's it like then when you
listening um you know that's how the
practice actually works and the filter
question or the lens through which you
look at your daily experience the
reframing of that by doing this
exercises a really important point so I
want to underscore that for people
listening and just to draw an analogy or
at least a parallel if you buy a new car
let's just say you buy a white
Volkswagen Golf it will seem that the
next day or the subsequent week that
there are white Volkswagen golf's
everywhere on the street but it's simply
because you've attuned your attention to
that particular object and my eye oh one
of my ex-girlfriends a debt of gratitude
because at one point she noticed that I
did have this habit of running my life
along a certain philosophical line which
was the good things will take care of
itself just tell me what's going wrong
and I didn't I didn't want the positive
feedback I wanted to know how I could
improve and what I needed to improve and
to remedy that at one point she created
this jar it was a big mason jar and she
just wrote on the side the jar of
awesome and what she had what she asked
me to do was every night just to write
down one really good thing that happened
that made me happy or made me grateful
that day and put it in the jar and it's
not that I was a total ingrate it's not
like I'm as ebony czar Scrooge or
anything but I would put down the things
that were good and I realized one of the
critical mistakes that I made and I'm
getting a little off track here
but I assumed that I would always
remember the good things
long-term because I found it second
nature to remember the bad things
long-term and it turned out that it was
a completely false assumption and I
would very quickly forget the good
things that happened and so my
girlfriend encouraged me to write down
these events or encounters whatever it
might be on a piece of paper and fill up
the jar and then when I was having a
down moment or being over judgmental
towards myself to just reach into the
jar
and rifle to go through it and to pick
out one or two examples and it was
really therapeutic for me but I still
have it to this day and the the question
of self-compassion or the topic of
self-compassion is one I want to come
back to and we were chatting before we
started recording a little bit about the
word love and how perhaps it's been
co-opted or used in in ways that have
made it challenging and could you please
elaborate on what you mean by that we
didn't get into it before we started so
I just for myself also this is a word
that is so often used it seems to have
almost lost a lot of meaning and so I'd
be curious to know how you wield it and
how you would suggest people think about
it well I think it has lost a lot of
meaning because we use the word love
from everything from you know I love the
color of that cabinet and I love frozen
yogurt - I love you and and there are so
many associations with love it's like I
mean one of the questions you posed
before you know if you are a person
who's kind of a type-a person and you're
brought into room and say we're gonna do
a meditation on love you know it tends
to be a little nauseated from people and
because we often associate love with
weakness with giving in kind of smiling
with you know it's just this frivolous
smile it's not connected maybe the very
deep wounds are pain or anger or our
edge or ferocity or intensity or the
things that are really a part of us and
it's a word in Pali the language of the
original Buddhist text is meta m ET ta
and it's commonly translated as
loving-kindness which I think has a
flavor of the actual meaning but it's a
kind of problematic term because nobody
really uses it like you wouldn't really
necessarily expect to go to a coffee
shop somewhere and hear the conversation
at the next table including the word
loving-kindness it's maybe he's a little
saccharine or removed from day to day
life and I've had scholars and
translators come to me and say
say love stop being so cutesy you know
you mean love but love is so complicated
and can also be frankly a medium of
exchange like I would love you as long
as following 15 conditions are Matt or I
would love myself as long as I never
make a mistake and it's so fragile it's
so breakable it's not really what meant
to means the literal translation I also
have a problem with the literal
translation is friendship and for me
friendship implies conviviality like
let's have dinner together or let's go
to the movies together I want to spend
time with you and love in in that sense
it meta does not mean that at all it
actually doesn't even imply a certain
action it's an inner space of connection
we acknowledge our lives are connected
that everybody counts everybody matters
doesn't mean I like you it doesn't mean
anyone want to spend any time with you
it doesn't mean I'm going to cease
fighting you and your agenda but not
from a place of hatred you know then
it's it's connection that's that's
really what it's about and so those
practices of say loving kindness
meditation are back connecting more
deeply to ourselves and connecting more
deeply to others what if someone feels
themselves steering towards anger in an
exchange with someone aside from the
mindfulness training or practice they
would do outside of that encounter is
there anything you recommend they do or
self talk they could use to defuse that
and steer it in a less antagonistic
direction I mean I think there are lots
of levels so that one is getting really
acquainted what's happening in your body
it's like you feel the beginning of the
anger not like after you've sent the
email or he's not lashed out but you can
feel it really emerging and then you
have choice and we also practice in
mindfulness being able to hang in there
with the anger you know without having
it take us over and also with that being
ashamed of it or afraid of it without
finding it but we have a more balanced
relationship to it and we can hang in
there it's almost like this storm moving
through your body and then you decide
how do you want to act this is often we
do have to act and
but you know maybe that very emails I
can get you what you want you know maybe
it's better to wait a moment and and see
what else he merges something like that
and there's also their kind of
intentionality
it's like we can remember our deepest
intention like what do I want to have
come out of this conversation what would
make me happiest I want to be seen as
right
do I want to grind them into dust do I
want to be helpful
do I want a resolution and that'll give
us a lot of information you know about
where we're really coming from and if
it's to have a resolution to find a way
to work together whatever it might be or
even finish dinner together you know
then that might council being quieter
and not being so forceful or
finding another way of saying this is
what I feel instead of this is the way
the truth is things like that and if you
in fact want to grind them into dust
that will be a different path mm-hmm
yeah the the this is how I feel frame is
one that I want to personally get better
at using because I think it's so easy a
at least for me
- unfortunately convey messages in a way
that seems very Spock like and if you
were to take the same content and have
someone transmit it with a smile and
preface it with this may be just how I
feel but I I think that I could have
avoided a lot of wasted time and energy
and hurt feelings and other people even
though it's exactly the same content in
effect the so two quick notes the first
is just since you mentioned email and
creating unnecessary messes I would
suggest to anyone out there one thing
I've learned if you're experimenting
with any type of fasting obviously with
proper medical supervision and so on
probably a good idea if you've never
done it before to not let yourself send
email on the second or third or third
day I've created a
lot of ugly disasters by Manning the
inbox during times like that the second
is something that I wanted to back into
that's related to what we've been
talking about and I thought was really
profound and worth highlighting for
people and that is that often times this
has certainly been true for me that
others if you were working on say your
meditation practice it also applies to
all sorts of things like medication in
some instances this happened to a friend
of mine when he started taking very low
dose lithium for instance others see the
changes in us before we see the changes
in ourselves and I'd love for you if you
could talk about that a little bit and I
can certainly give an example or two as
well but it's it strikes me that a lot
of people give up because they feel like
nothing has happened when in fact a lot
has happened they just can't yet
perceive it themselves so if you could
talk to that at all I'd love to hear
your additional thoughts because I think
it's really really important since so
many analytical sort of left brain
people think they're really really good
at self assessment and self awareness
but it's hugely hugely overestimated at
least in this capacity I think that's
really true and um I tell the story
sometimes about a friend who came to me
in New York City and took me out to
lunch and he said this is like the
confessional lunch I said oh really you
know he said he he had been doing
loving-kindness meditation that was just
his particular methodology he said I've
been doing loving-kindness meditation
for about three years now and I want to
say that my experience when I sit each
day or when I'm on retreat doing that
practice it's not that different now
than it was three years ago when I
started out but I'm like a totally
different person I'm different with
myself I'm different with my family I'm
different ethically I'm different with
my community and then he looked at me he
said is that enough I said yeah I think
it's kind of enough you know
so that's the first thing I say is if
you're trying to assess your practice
and you should you don't want to do
something forever not knowing if it's
making a difference but don't look at
that say 20 minute period a day when
you're formally practicing look at your
life yeah that's where we can see it I
mean you don't see it right away you're
totally right like usually other people
see it more in us first before we see it
in ourselves and have many people come
to me and say you know I wasn't stopped
anything anything was happening but my
kids came to me and said please don't
stop you're much better you know it was
so yeah you know the ultimate point is
to look at our lives maybe not right
away others will tell us if we're
changing but then when we are really
seriously assessing to look at your life
that's where it matters and you know I
think it's in our lives that we really
we do see the benefits if they're there
to be seen and that's where they matter
so that's where it should be the the
friend I mentioned had a very similar
experience
he runs pretty hot as as I do as a lot
of people do and his story was very
similar and I think applies equally to
meditation which he's also since started
but he began taking this very low dose
like five milligrams of lithium orotate
so caveat people talk to your medical
professionals but generally you would
expect safer as a mono therapy for
bipolar depression you'd be looking at
something like 1200 or 1500 milligrams
of lithium carbonates this is five
milligrams and he started taking it
didn't really notice anything took it
for a few weeks and then at one point he
was out with his wife and she was trying
on some shoes and she came out they kept
walking and he was telling her you know
I've actually been taking lithium for
the last week or two I haven't really
noticed anything and she said wait what
and rewound and she said do you realize
that you just said while I tried on
shoes for 45 minutes and did
complain she goes Kobayashi you've been
totally you've been totally different
with her and with the kids and what I've
found is that it's also really easy to
perceive a lack of progress because you
don't see yourself doing new things in
the rest of your life where what you
don't notice are the things that you're
doing less of if that makes sense
and what I have found for myself at
least it's it's very subtle
until someone points it out in you but
if I think of let's just say my
proneness to anger or impatience let's
just say there's a buffer so there's a
buffer between sort of control and then
externally throwing out anger or
impatience and there are certain things
that decrease that buffer that kind of
that safety zone like for me caffeine
for instance as a sleep deprivation but
when I meditate and do other practices
it increases the buffer so it takes more
and more and more to get me to that
threshold after which I lash out or send
the stupid brusky mail or whatever it
might be you know I love to
you mentioned the conditional love a
while back the if you satisfy these 15
requirements then I will love you if not
I will revoke my by my right to my or my
ability to love you whatever it might be
I've I've read a little bit maybe you
can elaborate on or tell the story about
the the man and his dog the hundred
hundred story could you could you share
that with the people listening please
because I I do I do like it I didn't I
only only read a very abbreviated
version that's great I recently read a
book called real love and the process of
writing the
I really tried a crowdsource in a way I
wanted to hear a lot of people's stories
and insights about love and some of that
I tried to do online a lot of it I did
meeting with groups and the very first
group I met with was in New York City
and people just were talking about their
experiences of love so the the
trajectory of the book the structure of
the book is that the first section is
about love for oneself the second
section is about love for another
whether that's a parent or child or a
lover or whatever and then third section
is about love for all beings so I just
said let it rip you know I don't care
which section you're talking about but
you know help me let tell me what love
means to you tell me some stories so
we've got through you know a good part
of the evening and this guy raised his
hand and he said you know most people
think of a good relationship is 50/50 he
said my dog and I were a hundred a
hundred there was perfect I love that
story and and then I was unfortunately
quite late with the book and I kept
getting delayed you know cuz me and
finally it was you know little over a
year ago and it was I was in England
about the city retreat I was just about
to press send it was a day early from
the final final deadline I felt really
proud Oh
daily and the I was just about to press
send when I remember that story and I
thought does that make it in there you
know did stay in there through all these
changes and editing's and stuff like
that so I looked and I had not so
quickly typed it in and I press sense it
was the last thing that got written
without going how do you so meeting
deadlines always a good feeling that
doesn't always happen with books if how
do you think about success if you use
that word or how would you like people
to redefine it life kind of redefined it
a lot in my own life in that I know now
you know like meditation mindfulness is
extremely popular and a lot of people
talk about scaling you know like let's
have a big impact on a lot of people
small impact on a lot of people but a
lot of people part is the is what's
critical for a lot of folks and when I
think about it you know it's not really
so much that way for me because you know
I am I feel really privileged I feel
incredibly lucky in my life the things I
get to talk about the things I get to
explore with people and their
willingness to be vulnerable and honest
and and the methods that you know were
given to me and I am able to pass on and
that I find really viable and useful and
life-saving in many cases and you know I
ask myself is it enough if one person or
three people or I have 100 people in
front of me and only three people you
know want to take it to some depth or or
whatever it is you know is that enough
and I actually kind of feel it's enough
because it's so amazing when somebody
says to you with that kind of sincerity
oh your work has really made a
difference or you know people recognize
my voice now because of recordings or
you know it's it's really a beautiful
thing and so I like anybody you know
have great conditioning toward like
numbers you know it's got to be this
many people or it's got to be these many
people per recording or something like
that and and as I get older of which I
have somehow you know I think they're
just you know really you know just think
of that one person hmm what are you what
are your biggest challenges right now I
mean are there any particular behaviors
you're trying to change problems you're
trying to solve if you're comfortable
discussing it because I think I think
it's very easy for people to assume that
you've got everything figured out that
you wake up and it's just one blissful
Zen moment to the next of self
compassion and loving kindness towards
everyone in the world but I would I
would imagine there's more to the
picture what are what are are there any
particular challenges or things you're
trying to change in your life right now
yeah just the story catch me that
I was sitting in it was actually the San
Francisco Airport and my flight was
delayed for six hours six and a half
after welcome to San Francisco thank you
for the first five and a half hours I
was fine and then I just got like so
irritated and I was so impatient I feel
so miserable and just then this woman
came up to me said Sharon Salzberg
you know on the floor three hours ago
you know there's a lot of that yeah I
mean I say yes to too many things I'm
tired and I'm a night out anyway you
know so if I good if I'm asleep by one
that's a good thing if I'm asleep by
three that's a bad thing I just had this
book came out and I was traveling like
crazy and I'm like so happy I'm getting
on another airplane for a few weeks and
and there's this great temptation in
this moment in time because you know I
remember coming back from India in
nineteen in 74 as a meditation teacher
because one of my own teachers had had
told me to teach so you know and in
those days if I was at a party or some
social situation introduced as a
meditation teacher people would kind of
sidle light like that's weird or you
know or they'd say you know did you meet
the Beatles when you were over there and
I'd say no sadly you know they went when
I was in high school but you know now
it's like so tempting there's so many
opportunities and you go so many I could
go so many places and reach so many
different kinds of people it's like wait
a minute and I like take a break mm-hmm
how do you how do you work through
improving any of those things how do you
think about making progress with
behavior change well I mean by the time
that my thousand friends have said to me
all right you look really tired yeah you
know maybe I should sleep early
what is worked well for you historically
when you feel overwhelmed or are in a
dark place are there any particular
times that come to mind for you in the
past they get where you could tell a
story and then what helped you get out
of it what whether that funk is
overwhelmed depression or some
combination yeah yeah I did write a book
called faith and faith in the Buddhist
tradition is not you know it's not like
a commodity you have or you don't have
and if you don't have enough for the
right kind you're you're condemned it's
more a process it's a journey and it's a
journey
faith is almost a fine just offering
your heart being able to be fully
present with something moving off of the
sidelines into the center of possibility
it's that movement and it's only aided
and strengthened by questioning and
doubt and wandering doubt the right kind
of debt you know like wanting to see the
truth for yourself so I was working with
this freelance editor a friend on the
book and and saying well you know from
the Buddhist point of view doubt is not
the right kind of job that insistence on
questioning it is not the opposite of
faith so she said what's the opposite of
faith and I said despair and then she
said well you're gonna have to tell a
despair story and in your book and I'd
really rather not you know I did and
it's the stories you know we started
this conversation talking about my
mother dying when I was nine and in the
book faith I talked about this time in
the 90s so that's you know thirty years
later more I was meditating I was in
Australia on an intensive retreat a
month-long intensive retreat with my
Burmese teacher Saito panditah who had
gone to Australia to teach and
out of nowhere I was kind of back there
I was nine years old and not knowing
what to do not knowing how to get help
and the you know the the terror and the
anguish and the whole thing it was just
there and it was one of those moments
where I thought I thought I worked
through this you know I thought this was
done and through a whole process a lot
relying on him and his trust in me and
the practice and just being in nature
and things like that I really saw that
despair was like the severing of
connection that faith was like
connection like love which I'm also
defining as connection so I'm realizing
I'm kind of back there again so I
realized that everything I could do that
would renew my sense of connection and
kind of bring me to that sense of you
know not being so alone not being
severed from life itself and there was
at the time this um passage from real
key came up in my mind something like do
not be frightened if a sadness greater
than you've ever known before comes up
before you life has not forgotten you I
love that and that really became my much
of life has not forgotten me I'm still a
part of life life has not forgotten me
and maybe you know that first class I
did in in Asian philosophy was the
beginning of that you know everybody
suffers this is a part of life life has
not forgotten you you haven't been
abandoned and so when you know I feel
that I mean I don't really feel it often
but if I feel the intimations of that
reemerging it's all about connection hmm
well I know we have some time
constraints today but I think that is I
think that's it that's actually a very
good place to just hit pause for a
second and I want to I didn't do this
upfront
but I was planning on it so here it is I
wanted to thank you personally for the
work that you put out in the world
because it's had an impact on me I've
listened to your audio I've read a lot
of your writing and I want to I suppose
reaffirm what you said earlier about
success and not necessarily reaching for
scale from the outset but focusing on
one person at a time because your work
has impacted me which has helped me to
also try to do better things in the
world so from a very personal standpoint
I just want to thank you for doing what
you do well thank you really and I
continue to read your work and I am I
would highly recommend people check out
real love and certainly for people
listening I'm going to link to that as
well as anything that we've spoken about
in this episode in the show notes at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast as per
usual but i'm wondering if there's if
there's any ask that you have or
recommendation of the audience that you
have before we before we draw to a close
are there any parting comments or words
that you would like to share could be
could be anything really with the people
who are listening yeah I mean I do find
this thank you and I do find this such a
time of grief and the part of people and
rage and so many people say to me I
can't bear who I've become I'm
continually in rage and you know my hope
is always that love be a part of the
conversation and that that we in a way I
guess it's why I'm glad the book came
out when it came out because it's so
easy to think of love as being weak and
saccharine and all of that and it's so
easy to think the only strength we have
is vengefulness and hatred and I hope we
just keep looking at that altogether and
understand that we can fight and
struggle and we kind of
have to because what a time but you know
it can come from a different place and
it's kind of got to come from a
different place I know that quotation
from Einstein is a little suspect you
know because you can never really source
it where he apparently said somewhere
you know the problems that we face
cannot be solved by the same level of
thinking that created them but it sounds
right like Betty did say it and it's an
amazing statement and you know I think
about that really a lot I hope people I
mean my deepest hope is that people will
do the good that's in front of them even
if she feels very small because the
problems right now it can seem
insurmountable and massive and and we
just have to step by step do what we can
do the good that's in front of you that
is that's advice that everybody needs to
hear I I think it's so important so
thank you a and B what's in front of you
is concrete I think this is also why a
lot of people feel overwhelmed is that
the the big the macro the global
economic political fill-in-the-blank
tend to be very very abstract and and
and it's difficult to sort of grapple
with a shadow in that sense and rather
than focusing on the things you cannot
control are the things that you will not
attempt to control work with what's
right in front of you and it's those
small acts done by one or several or
many people that ultimately create the
large-scale the large-scale change so do
the good that's in front of you I
appreciate that
and people can certainly find you on
social if they want to say hello do you
have a preferred location on the
internet for people to say hello well
I'm on Twitter a lot that Sharon
Salzberg and my website is Sharon
Salzberg calm and you can actually reach
me through there as well perfect
well Sharon thank you so much I hope we
have a chance to to meet in person or do
around two and I'll definitely keep you
posted on the goings-on or not goings on
during my first ten day yeah I'd love to
hear it really that's me sometime so to
be continued thank you very much for the
time and just to repeat for everybody
listening you can find links to
everything we've discussed including the
books and so on
at tim dialogue forward slash podcast
and until next time thank you for
listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday if that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour work week calm
all is spelled out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma Dec founded by the genius Finn's
who lit the internet on fire and you may
have heard of their mushroom coffee
which features chaga and lion's mane
which has taken Silicon Valley by storm
I use it pretty much every day either
that or the chaga which is decaf a
separate version and I use both of these
primarily for focus and productivity
they just get you
let you up like a Christmas trees
definitely check it out people are
always asking me what I use for
cognitive enhancement and for right now
this is the answer I try to force this
on all of my houseguests it is a hell of
a thing but I have employees or people
come over who are working on projects
with me I always try to feed it to them
because I'm going to get the limitless
effect if a lot we're out of them the
first time I mentioned this product and
for sig Matic on the podcast their
products sold out in less than a week so
you may want to check them out soon if
you're listening to this and the coffee
tastes like coffee
it takes just seconds to prepare with
hot water and oddly enough only includes
40 milligrams of caffeine so it has less
than half of what you get in a regular
cup of coffee I don't get any jitters
acid reflux or any stomach burn any of
that it's very unusual and very very
cool so if you don't like caffeine they
also offer very strong but caffeine free
mushroom collectors which I will
sometimes have in the evening I find
chaga specifically to be very very
grounding and earthy so that is another
option and I have a cupboard full of
their products at the motor which is
right around the corner in my kitchen
you can try something you can try a
sample pack which is great also right
now by going to four sig Matic calm for
Tosh Tim that's four sig Matic fo you
are SI g ma TI c comport / Tim and use
the code Tim TI m to get 20% off of your
first order and they're not that
expensive anyway if you are in the
experimental mindset I do not think
you'll be disappointed so try them this
episode is brought to you by convertkit
my go-to email service provider a lot of
you have asked me what I use for email
and I have been hesitant to tell you
because I don't want to give them the
hug of death and have my own service
drop so after much consideration I
finally said yes to convertkit
being a sponsor email is a huge priority
for me and I trust convertkit as my ESP
my email service provider it's the only
platform that I can completely control
and customize and I need a service that
ensures the right information is sent to
my followers and listeners and I can
afford downtown a very little patience
for it so tried all sorts of different
platforms and ultimately selected
convertkit because they deliver on what
matters most to me and my team
easy-to-use systems
split testing super important and
resending technology say to on opens
high rates of deliverability and
excellent customer service when I've
needed something from them when my team
has needed something from them they've
always been there so whether you run a
business or just have a professional
blog let's say convertkit offers email
automation which allows you to send well
time targeted content to your audience
or your customers the platform has all
sorts of integrations with more than 35
services including say hosting sites
such as WordPress e-commerce platforms
like Shopify lead capture technology
like bounce exchange or sumo and many
many more they offer plans that can
adjust to meet the size of your business
and they can scale with you so
convertkit can handle you whether you
have a thousand people or 1 million
people on your email list let's take a
look convert kit.com forward slash Tim
that's Co NV e RT ki T compote slash Tim
and you can get your first month for
free that way you can test the platform
kick the tires make sure that it works
for you and your business and if you're
like me hopefully fingers crossed
because I only like to recommend things
that scale and do really well for
everybody I hope that you find they get
the job done that's certainly been the
case for me again that is convertkit com
forward slash Tim for a free month of
email services check it out
you
you